meanwhile you know my friend andrew
breitbart used to say that culture is
upstream of politics and it is true
when you hear from all of your cultural
sources all of them that america is
systemically racist and evil
you start to believe it and when you see
that people are called out and cudgelled
into line if they don't repeat that
narrative you start to say to yourself
well maybe i should do that too
right maybe i need to say all this woke
stuff because if i don't say that woke
stuff i'll get fired from my job at
woca cola or maybe i will be tossed out
by my local university or maybe all of
my friends will unfriend me on facebook
okay this is infused even some of our
most apolitical
dumb cultural institutions so i say dumb
because i will
freely admit to you i am not a a watcher
of the bachelor i think the premise of
the show is idiotic
frankly the the notion that you have one
person who's dating 20 people at once i
think it's kind of perverse
the fact that people think this is
romantic is absolutely beyond me it must
be part of the lizard brain
that sees any sort of romantic gesture
as romantic even if it's done
in the context of a highly and slickly
produced
program in which a dude is dating 20
chicks at once
okay but in any case being a non-fan of
the bachelor i think this gives me in
some ways more credibility to talk about
the stupidity
of what is now going on at the bachelor
okay the bachelor has been in a
political show that men have not wanted
to watch for 25 years
it's the kind of show where your wife
turns it on and watches it and is
enthralled and you
sit there and you just wish that you
could turn the channel to football
but it is one of the key institutional
cultural touchstones of our society
clearly right i mean it's been around
for forever
right it's an insta it's a cultural
institution in america it's been one of
the highest rated shows on tv
since 2002. it has been
around it has been around more than half
my life on tv
okay so now the bachelor is imploding
and it's imploding
because there is a contestant named
rachel connell and rachel corconell
several years ago went to a
antebellum-themed
plantation party when she was in college
this involved basically dressing up like
scarlett o'hara at a plantation
and this was considered wildly uncouth
and racist and covered by the internet
sleuths
those great people doing amazing things
like suggesting that people are racist
because they dressed up as scarlett
o'hara
at a an antebellum themed party
in the south as though this was sort of
some sort of referendum on slavery that
probably rachel kirk connell was totally
cool with slavery because of this
probably that was that is the most
obvious takeaway right i mean that's the
most obvious takeaway okay so
when that first came out the contestant
on the bachelor of the season is a black
man his name is matt james
and matt james originally
came out on february 3rd and reacted
by asking for some grace for her matt
james here's what matt james
said here's a direct quote i have not
spoken to anybody since the show ended
but i would say that you have to be
really careful about what you are doing
on social media
rumors are dark and they're nasty and
they can ruin people's lives so i would
give people the benefit of the doubt
and hopefully she will have her time to
speak on that
now spoiler alert i mean it's well all
over the noise but here's the news but
here's your spoiler alert if you're one
of the
number of of people who for some odd
reason loved the show
matt did end up with rachel in the show
right he picked her
he ended up with her and that was matt
james the black contestant
on the bachelor saying we should show
her some grace the social media judge
jury they should they really should not
be doing what they're doing people on
social media decided to check into like
her parents voting record
they decided that she had to be canceled
because she went to this antebellum
theme party and boy isn't it fun
to go get this lady let's just go right
after this lady because she disagrees
politically with us or her parents
disagree politically with us
and also she went to an ill-advised
themed party in 2018
when she was in college okay so that's
the setup
the setup is that she does something
that is
somewhat questionable in in the modern
context but certainly not questionable
as
even five ten years ago and i mean
at that point it would have been
considered kind of crazy to cancel
somebody over something like this now
you cancel somebody over literally
saying the n word to denounce the n word
so
everything is cancellable but it was so
crazy that even matt james the black
bachelor was like uh yeah guys
you need to give her some space okay
that is the setup that is the setup
fast forward about three weeks
right because that was february 3rd
february 3rd the bachelor contestant
matt james comes out and defends her
and then a couple days later chris
harrison who's the host of the bachelor
he comes out and says basically the
exact same thing as matt ames right
just a couple days later he comes out he
does an interview and he says maybe we
should show her some grace
social media is not judged during an
executioner you're ruining somebody's
life maybe you ought to take into
account the fact that she was young and
stupid when you're young and stupid or
young and stupid
maybe she can explain herself maybe
she'll apologize
okay and then chris harrison got hit
with the with the
anvil of wokism he was just dropped on
his head from the third story
and so he ended up being suspended from
his own show
for the great crime of suggesting that a
young woman ought to be given grace
saying the exact same thing in nearly
the exact same words that matt james
said them
okay the reason that this all started is
because there's a former bachelor
contestant named rachel lindsay
okay so rachel lindsay went after chris
harrison and said it was racist of him
he didn't understand she said when she
was not cutting ads for cadillac in the
middle of the black lives matter protest
she said that it was very very important
that chris harrison understood the
context of his own
racist sentiment and the producers of
the bachelor wanting to avoid
controversy then removed chris harrison
from the final episodes of the bachelor
which is kind of incredible actually
okay fast forward about three weeks now
matt james who by the way
picked rachel connell again he picked
her after defending her at the beginning
of february
now he has issued a full-scale statement
not only
denouncing rachel kirk connell and
throwing her under the bus i mean this
guy's
what a douchebag honestly seriously he
was defending her three weeks ago what
changed in three weeks other than he
didn't like the media blowback
so he took a girl who was dating him
right and then he just tossed her under
the bus and the show
that made him a star and a relevant
person in american life
the first black bachelor a show so
apparently racist
that you had women of all different
racial makeups
dating the main character who's black so
obviously this is a deeply racist
terrible show now matt james has flipped
on a dime
and now he says the show is racist chris
harrison is racist and he
is woke which makes this guy not only a
douchebag but a coward
so matt james put out a statement and
says the past few weeks have been some
of the most challenging my life
and while there are several episodes
left of the season it is important that
i take the time to address the troubling
information that has come to light since
we wrapped filming
including the incredibly disappointing
photos of rachel corconell and the
interview between
rachel lindsay and chris harrison wow
so he went from let's give her some
grace and treat people like human beings
too i'm incredibly disappointed in
everyone around me and it's definitely
not my fault and please leave me alone
and maybe i should be on the cover of a
magazine
talking about racial problems in america
matt james writes the reality is that
i'm learning about these situations in
real time
oh really because uh back on february 30
you knew about them so
if by in real time you knew that the
photos were out at the beginning of
february and you defended her and now
you're too much of a coward to stand by
it
there's that he said it's been
devastating and heartbreaking to put it
bluntly
chris's failure to receive and
understand the emotional labor
that my friend rachel lindsay was taking
on by graciously and patiently
explaining the racist history of the
antebellum south
a painful history that every american
should understand intimately was
troubling and painful to watch okay
that's just pathetic i'm sorry that's
ridiculous
ridiculous the labor and pain the
emotional labor rachel lindsay was
taking on
again this is a lady who in the middle
of the black lives matter protest she's
like you know how i
fight for black lives matter i put on
podcasts talking about
about black history in my beautiful
cadillac xt6
i'm not kidding that's an actual
instagram post she put up
okay it is a po it is a post in which
she touts black lives matter
and she says she can listen to podcasts
about black history on her beautiful
bose sound system in her cadillac xt
xt6 emotional labor my ass
rachel lindsay couldn't be reveling in
this anymore if you paid her and they
are paying her
emotional labor come on yeah she seemed
i mean it must be real emotional labor
having to explain to people that they
should be cancelled
not because they're actively racist or
believe in the inferiority of black
people but that they should be canceled
because they suggest grace for a person
who went to a party that was ignorant
and and that should be that's cancelable
and not only that the person who says
maybe we should give that person grace
give them a chance to explain themselves
and apologize
to even explain to that person to even
explain to that person
is emotional labor you cannot even
explain to chris harrison that is an
emotion
it's an act of emotional labor emotional
labor
honestly god pay me for that kind of
emotional labor give me a cadillac
sponsorship for that kind of emotional
labor
emotional labor as black people and
allies immediately knew and understood
it was a clear reflection of a much
larger issue
that the bachelor franchise has fallen
short on addressing adequately for years
again
matt james is the first black bachelor
the first one okay and rachel lindsay
was the contestant on the bachelor she's
very famous now
this is yes that is nailed it right matt
you nailed it
it turns out that it has dawned on you
now that you are a participant in the
most richest franchise in american
history obviously the bachelor
is like birth of a nation except with
dating and a black lead
who's the hero and him dating a bunch of
uh
lindsey by the way was the first black
bachelorette forgive me for my ignorance
on matters concerning the bachelor one
of the dumbest shows of all time
matt james continues this moment has
sparked critical conversations and
reporting no it has not
it has sparked stupid conversations and
bad reporting raised important questions
no it has not the only important
question is
why is it that you are running away from
your own
from your own willingness to grant
people the benefit of the doubt
people you are dating by the way and
then the minute that there's some
blowback you throw her under the bus
and you suggest that you're a hero for
doing so and resulted in inspiring
displays of solidarity from the bachelor
nation
it has also pushed me to reevaluate and
process what my experience on the
bachelor represents
oh so now he's going to re-evaluate
right we're going to go back and we're
going to re-process
they're really going to think hard about
what a rough life he had dating 20 women
at once
on national television and being paid
for the privilege
it has pushed me to reevaluate and
process what my experience on the
bachelor represents not just for me
but of all the contestants of color oh
no he's a representative of all black
americans black americans you understand
this guy
represents you apparently according to
him especially the black contestants of
this season and seasons past and for you
the viewers at home i will continue to
process this experience and you'll hear
more from me
in the end my greatest prayer is that
this is an inflection point that results
in real and institutional change for the
better
i'm sorry this is the stupidest crap
i've ever heard it does not make the
culture better it makes the culture
significantly worse
if you look at this season of the
bachelor as a victory
for american racial tolerance you're
missing you're missing it
because what it was was a victory for
conciliation
and then the woke came and decided to
completely destroy everything
and the bachelor again he started it man
he started it he defended kurt connell
he defended her
at the beginning of february and within
three weeks he has flipped he's not only
inciting kurt connell as a racist he's
indicting chris harrison as a racist and
the entire bachelor franchise is a
racist
as racist he's doing all of that within
three weeks because rachel lindsay said
you are you are obviously a sellout
essentially right i mean that must have
been the case that she was making
publicly
or at least he felt that way pretty
incredible stuff there
pretty incredible stuff because the show
ain't racist you know what the proof is
that the show ain't racist
the show there is no good evidence that
rachel corconell is a racist
not only did she post a groveling
apology
for the antebellum stuff she's put out a
bunch of statements
since that rachel lindsay has found
insufficient and rachel lindsay as the
pope
of wokeness gets to determine whether or
not you are
sufficiently whether you're sufficiently
deferential to woke principles
and she'll do so while standing in front
of a cadillac xts by the way it's
xt6 it's impressive stuff i will admit
because nothing says america is racist
quite like getting to rip america as
racist the show that you start in as
racist
the host of that show as racist other
contestants on that show as racist
and the entire system of the united
states is racist while standing in front
of a beautiful cadillac
xt6 with a bose sound system
clearly this is an awful awful country
for people like rachel lindsay clearly
she has suffered greatly in her life
clearly matt james has suffered the
emotional labor oh
the emotional labor oh emotional labor
my ass
seriously ridiculous ridiculous stuff
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content